et pourquoi faire vous vous souvenez
c'était ce que répondait Manu aux
inconnus dans ce sketch lorsqu'on lui
proposait de descendre dans la rue et
pourquoi faire c'est sans doute que
demande Emmanuel Macron à tous ceux qui
descendent dans la rue aujourd'hui pour
protester une fois encore contre la
réforme des retraites il est 14h09
bonjour bienvenue sur le figarolive nous
suivons ensemble cette 14e oui déjà 14e
journée de mobilisation avec cette
question lancinante et pourquoi faire
bonjour Marie-Cécile Renaud bonjour mon
cher Thibault du service économie du
Figaro merci d'être ici vous vous
souvenez de ce sketch et pourquoi faire
et Manu tu descends pour être honnête
non
internautes connaissent très bien plein
de questions pour vous Vincent roseron
vous vous connaissez ce sketch des
Inconnus donnez-nous le parcours vous
êtes sur place
oui effectivement alors le parcours il
se trouve il débarque là où je suis
actuellement sur la place des Invalides
vous le voyez derrière moi le cortège de
l'Inter syndical qui est là et qui va
démarrer d'ici quelques instants d'ici
pour aller jusqu'à la Place d'Italie du
coup un cortège habituel maintenant l'un
des cortèges habituels pour cette 14e
journée de mobilisation sur le parcours
il y a un endroit où on a vu c'est la
manifestation qu'il y avait souvent des
débordements c'est la rotonde ce
restaurant ou Emmanuel Macron avait ses
habitudes on va voir ce qu'il en sera
cette fois-ci et donc voilà pour le
planning de cette de cette manifestation
est-ce qu'il y a déjà un peu du un peu
du monde parce que c'est toujours l'une
des questions qu'on se pose autour de
vous 14h10 c'est l'heure à laquelle doit
se lancer le cortège l'impression que
c'est clairsemé autour de vous mais bon
la place des Invalides c'est grand
[Musique]
alors la place dans ma vie c'est grand
mais effectivement c'est clair ce mail
vous pouvez le voir sur les images
devient Leclerc qui m'accompagne en ce
moment vous voyez cette place assez
clairsemée il faut le savoir que là nous
sommes au début du cortège officiel
entre guillemets et que on voit des gens
affluer et avancer un peu en amont de ce
cortège avancé petit à petit déjà parce
que ce cortège devait partir à 14h il
est 14h10 il est toujours pas parti
parce qu'il attend en fait Sophie Binet
qui est en interview et qui vient
d'arriver justement avec l'Inter
syndical Sophie Binet et Laurent Berger
d'ailleurs les deux se sont exprimés
aujourd'hui
il y a un peu plus d'une heure
maintenant Laurent Berger qui a dit
celui qui est encore le patron de la CDT
pour quelques jours c'est la dernière
manifestation sur la question des
retraites dans ce format alors que
Sophie Binet de son côté son homologue
de la CGT assure la tenue d'autres
manifestations au vu de la situation
sociale du pays
merci Vincent revient évidemment très
rapidement vers vous si vous avez des
personnalités syndicales des
personnalités politiques vous pouvez
évidemment réagir sur le Figaro.fr sur
Youtube je commence à poser les
premières questions à Marie Cécile
Renaud nouvelle journée de grève alors
on lâche rien du côté des syndicats oui
mais enfin vous le voyez à l'écran c'est
fini c'est le chant du signe c'est
terminé d'ailleurs Laurent Berger l'a
dit ce matin sur Europe 1 le match est
en train de se terminer il l'a dit
lui-même et voyez vous vous souvenez mon
cher Thibault puisque nous suivons
depuis 5 mois c'est 14 journées de
mobilisation en janvier le cortège
n'était pas parti le 31 janvier je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez le cortège ne
partez pas parce que il était tellement
fourni tellement long que la tête de
cortège n'était pas encore arrivée que
le la queue ne pouvait pas partir et là
le cortège ne part pas pourquoi parce
qu'on attend Sophie Binet qui est en
retard vous voyez c'est plus quand même
le même le même la même ambiance la même
atmosphère
millions de 170 000 personnes
aujourd'hui on attend entre 400 et 600
000 voilà c'est ça donc on sent bien
tout le monde est déjà dans l'après je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez on disait
que tout serait figés si cette réforme
passait que rien ne serait plus possible
qu'aucune discussion ne serait bien ne
serait possible en réalité tout le monde
est déjà dans l'après Stanislas Guérini
par exemple
négocier en ce moment avec les syndicats
de fonctionnaires il les a vu en
bilatéral il les reçoit lundi en
multilatérale pour parler des de
l'augmentation des salaires enfin des
rémunérations de la fonction publique
donc voyez bien que tout le monde se
projette déjà dans la suite et donc
après cinq mois de mobilisation cette
14e journée de mobilisation risque fort
d'être la dernière sur le sujet sur le
sujet des retraites du moins donc mon
cher Thibault nous n'aurons plus
l'occasion de nous retrouver comme ça
pour analyser les images sur ce sujet
sur ce
jusqu'au bout il y a pas eu de distance
secondes c'est vrai qu'ils ont tenu
bon et qu'il y a encore même si c'est
beaucoup moins qu'au départ il y a
encore aujourd'hui dans la rue 400000 à
600000 personnes sur toute la France et
40 000 à 70 000 à Paris qui a encore eu
des actions je sais pas si vous avez vu
les électriciens ont coupé une partie
d'ici les Moulineaux ce qu'il y a
handicapé orange enfin des entreprises
du numérique et des télécoms
mais
bon
la CGT elle continue à dire qu'elle ne
lâche rien mais on voit bien quand même
que ça y est je vous le disais tout le
monde est dans l'après et en train de de
voir la suite alors qu'on entend ce
chant l'international oui on connaît la
connotation de ces manifestants si on
toujours alors il y a eu des stratégies
différentes en tout cas il y a eu une
stratégie unique mais avec en son sein
dans cette inter syndicale de poids des
poids parfois être pour être plus
radicaux et puis de l'autre côté la CFDT
qui retenait la CGT est-ce que
finalement ils sont en train de
s'éloigner petit à petit désormais
ils n'ont jamais été sur la même ligne
là il y avait une
conjonction de d'intérêt et donc il y
avait une alliance d'opportunité mais
ils sont quand même
non finalement étaient ensemble que pour
essayer d'être plus fort mais sans avoir
les mêmes idées pas du tout les mêmes
idées c'est sûr que c'est finalement la
seule chose qu'ils ont le seul la seule
chose qu'ils ont gagné c'est de montrer
qu'ils étaient capables de faire l'unité
de se rassembler au-delà de leur
divergences pour peser et c'est vrai que
le fait d'être uni ça leur a donné plus
de poids donc ça
mais au final ils n'ont pas gagné
grand-chose parce que
les seuls éléments qui ont fait les
seuls points sur lequel le gouvernement
en tout cas les syndicats n'ont rien
obtenu les seuls points sur lequel le
gouvernement a évolué ce sont des points
qui ont été gagnés à l'Assemblée dans le
combat politique par finalement la
droite que ce soit sur l'extension des
carrières longues c'est la droite à
l'assemblée qui a obtenu que les
carrières longues englobe les gens qui
ont travaillé avant 21 ans
c'est le Sénat la droite qui a obtenu
des mesures pour les maires de famille
voyez donc en fait ce n'est pas les
syndicats mais
bon à l'heure actif il y a cette cette
effort pour dépasser les divergences et
créer une unité et limiter quand même
globalement la violence
on va se pencher
d'abord sur la CGT puis ensuite sur la
CFDT Marie-Cécile on commande ces images
en effet l'alcortège qui semble cette
relance et de l'Esplanade des Invalides
il y a pas grand monde en tout cas mais
évidemment
nous attendons d'avoir les chiffres plus
officiels et puis d'attendre parfois les
gens arrivent un peu plus tard un marais
Cécile sur les sur les manifestations
nous verrons bon alors la CGT elle veut
poursuivre que veut Sophie Binet
oui bah ils ne veulent passer des ils
veulent continuer mais
je veux dire le personne se fait
d'illusion le texte a été voté il va
être appliqué et donc bon là il se
rejoignent avec Laurent Berger qui qui
veut transformer cette colère maintenant
en revendication plus large sur des
sujets plus larges comme par exemple le
pouvoir d'achat l'organisation du
travail les conditions de travail la
pénibilité voyez tous ces sujets qui
finalement n'ont pas tellement été
abordés durant la
période de retraites puisque on était
dans une opposition
là pendant presque 6 mois sur cette
question
c'était le niet absolu retrait de la
réforme avant de pouvoir parler d'autre
chose bon bah maintenant le texte est
voté il va être appliqué les décrets
sont en cours de rédaction
les caisses de retraite se préparent à
la mise en oeuvre donc là il y a pas
grand chose à espérer Sophie Binet tiens
on peut parler de ses premiers pas alors
on l'imaginait plus peut-être plus douce
parce qu'elle venait de la CGT cadre
c'est ça
moins ferme qu'un certain Philippe
Martinez pas forcément le cas elle
semble elle aussi
être prêt à aller au combat jusqu'au
bout du bout du bout oui elle a une tête
d'ange on le dit souvent mais il faut
pacifier c'est une dure je vous rappelle
que la candidate de Philippe Martinez
c'était Marie buisson qui venait de
l'enseignement qui venait de la
fédération de l'enseignement et que ce
n'est pas elle qui a été choisie lors de
ce congrès mémorable de la CGT à
Clermont-Ferrand et qui avait eu une une
past d'armes voilà jusqu'au bout de la
nuit il y avait d'un côté la ludur il y
avait de l'autre côté de l'aile plutôt
plus conciliante celle de Martinez et
puis finalement ils se sont accordés sur
un choix
moyen celui de Sophie Binet je vous
rappelle dans une ambiance incroyable
survolté avec les gens qui menaçaient de
d'en venir aux mains
vous avez raconté clairement et il avait
été très surpris que de de l'atmosphère
alors que j'ai des mois qu'on disait
c'est bon Philippe Martinez a choisi sa
successeur pas du tout aider le cas et
Sophie Binet a émergé un peu du chapeau
on la connaissait pas on apprend à la
connaître on se rend compte qu'elle est
dur oui tout à fait c'est pas du tout la
ligne conciliante qui l'a emporté bien
au contraire ça
c'est le côté la CFDT désormais alors je
salue white Walter sur Youtube la CFDT
dernier round pour Laurent Berger le 21
juin il n'est plus à lui non ça fait 10
ans qu'il est à la tête de la salle de
thé il avait dit il avait annoncé qu'il
partirait avant la fin de son mandat
donc là on y est ça correspond à un
tournant il y a eu un changement de tête
à la CGT il a choisi de clore cette
cette séquence retraite et donc il s'en
va et il laisse le relais à son adjointe
Marylise Léon qui est dans la même ligne
ils sont très on la voit souvent dès que
Laurent Berger s'exprime elle est juste
à droite ou juste à gauche de lui là en
arrière-plan donc ils sont très proches
hein
ils sont complètement raccords donc je
pense que c'est vraiment la continuité
le même esprit même si forcément elle
imprimera sa personnalité si le fait
d'être une femme probablement fera
qu'elle prendra les choses d'une façon
un peu différente mais il y a vraiment
aucune
[Musique]
la proposition liotte
dont on a beaucoup parlé et qui sera
le défi tout à l'heure à Guillaume
Rocket qui viendra sur ce plateau de
nous résumer tout ça parce que demander
lui mais bon elle doit être débattue
cette proposition liotte doit être
débattue jeudi à l'Assemblée est-ce que
la Commission préalable la rejeté il y a
quand encore une possibilité qui a un
amendement qui devrait être lui aussi
rejeté mais c'est contraire à la
Constitution à l'article 40 de la
Constitution qui prévoit qu'une
proposition de loi ne peut pas créer une
charge financière supplémentaire pour
l'État donc
il y a peu de suspense pourquoi les
syndicats continuent est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose de très individualiste
d'une certaine manière il y a un
renouveau des syndicats tout le monde
s'accorde à le dire on les croyait mort
après la séquence des gilets jaunes
c'est visiblement par le cas ils sont
capables de mettre un million de 170 000
personnes dans la rue
est-ce que ils veulent capitaliser
là-dessus
non je voulais dire à
chaque cas et notamment sur les crises
la retraite qui sont des sujets très
très
angoissant pour les gens anxiogènes à
qui concerne tout le monde parce que par
exemple une réforme sur le chômage
concerne quand même une partie de la
population tandis que là la retraite ça
concerne tout le monde voyait et donc
les réformes des retraites elles ont
toujours toujours une capacité à mettre
énormément de monde dans la rue et à
chaque fois le schéma est le même
effectivement les syndicats engrangent
plus de militants
au climax de la crise au plus fort des
manifestations donc ils ont grandi mais
oui c'est toujours le cas et donc si
vous voulez maintenant ils vont essayer
de transformer cette cette énergie se
dynamisme cette force et de l'orienter
vers d'autres sujets ce qu'on disait
pouvoir d'achat conditions de travail
etc des revendications plus larges que
les seules retraites mais
et donc il pourrait il faut essayer de
transformer cette colère mais
les cinquième vont devoir aussi gérer
la déception la désillusion de ces gens
qu'ils ont emmenés dans la rue qui
vous savez bien commencer quand on va
dans des manifestations on est dans le
cortège on est porté par la foule par
cet élan on a l'impression
on en fait et on voit bien que les gens
ils croient ils se montrent
de l'argent
ils sont sur place ils ont l'impression
d'être très nombreux ils sont ils sont
au cœur de du cortège donc il ne voit
que ça et en fait il y a une forme de de
gueule de bois un peu au réveil s'il ne
se passe rien les gens ont un peu la
gueule de bois ils ont fait la fête
c'est le festif les cortèges les
manifestations on se tient les coudes on
est tous ensemble et puis s'il ne se
passe rien mais les syndicats vont aussi
devoir gérer cette déception cette
désillusion et et les
militants les ou les les les
les personnes qui se sont déplacées vont
quand même s'apercevoir que tout ça pour
rien vous disiez tout ça pourquoi mais
c'est un peu tout ça pour rien enfin pas
grand chose parce que je vous dis les
avancées ça plutôt été gagné par la par
les politiques
à l'Assemblée parce que on est dans un
quinquennat très particulier où
le président n'a pas d'assemblée n'a pas
de majorité à l'assemblée
que certains auront peut-être une une
gueule de bois après c'est long moi de
manifestation c'est nombreuses
manifestations nous en sommes à la 14e
Vincent roseron vous êtes sur place
est-ce que vous sentez encore de
l'espérance ou comme le dit Marie-Cécile
peut-être une un début de gueule de bois
la grève le défaire
alors il y a toujours de l'espérance
forcément il y a toujours des gens qui
qui montrent qu'ils y croient en tout
cas à ce à se retrait à cette abrogation
de la réforme des retraites mais
clairement là de ce qu'on a vu depuis
qu'on est arrivé on est encore qu'au
début même si on se retourne vers le
cortège principal on voit une rue assez
remplie finalement par rapport à la
préservalides comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure qui est assez grande et
compliqué à remplir néanmoins on sent
quand même que c'est plus clairsemé que
on a pu le connaître sur les précédentes
mobilisations
clairsemé visiblement Marie Cécile bon
vous êtes venu plusieurs fois sur splato
me dire que toutes ces mesures sucrées
avaient rendu la réforme inutile ou
presque j'exagère un peu j'exagère un
peu ne me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai
pas dit que finalement toutes ces
économies qui pouvaient être faites elle
n'était plus faite à cause de ces
mesures sucrées sauf qu'entre temps le
Conseil constitutionnel est passé par là
et à retoquer beaucoup de mesures
sucrées est-ce qu'elle redevient
intéressante cette réforme après le
passage devant le Conseil
constitutionnel surtout Thibault ne me
faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit
et j'ai toujours défendu cette réforme
comme étant nécessaire indispensable
enfin nécessité féloi d'ailleurs on a
bien vu qu'on était passé
à deux cheveux de la dégradation on
n'est pas on a senti le vent du boulet
de canon et que probablement si on n'a
pas été si la de la France n'a pas été
dégradé c'est parce que on a réussi même
à faire passer cette réforme des
retraites qui étaient absolument
indispensables vu l'état de nos finances
publiques donc et je voulais dire 100
fois enfin on l'a dit vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens vis-à-vis des
marchés
et vis-à-vis de l'état de nos finances
publiques donc cette réforme elle était
absolument nécessaire après ce que je
vous disais c'est qu'on aurait pu aller
plus loin puisque je vous le rappelle la
promesse d'Emmanuel Macron lors de la
campagne présidentielle c'était de
reporter l'âge non pas à 64 ans mais à
65 ans c'est ce qu'il avait annoncé
il demeure néanmoins des mesures sucrées
qui sont très coûteuses je pense
notamment à l'élargissement du
dispositif carrière longue alors qui a
été obtenu c'était toute la
contradiction
sous la pression de la droite à l'AS à
l'Assemblée le
alors que le la droite est plutôt pour
l'orthodoxie budgétaire enfin bon c'est
donc sous la houlette de Aurélien
Pradier qu'on a obtenu cette extension
du dispositif carrière longue aux gens
qui ont travaillé avant 21 ans et c'est
un dispositif qui est assez coûteux qui
permet aux gens de partir avant
avant l'âge légal et il avait beaucoup
augmenté on était monté à 180 000
départs par an en 2012 après le décret
Hollande qui avait mis ça en place et
puis mon petit à petit ça retombait on
était retombées à 140 000 et là avec
cette avec la réforme on va remonter on
va repartir à allègrement à plus de 200
000 départs anticipés avant l'âge légal
d'ici deux ans donc voyez il y a aussi
des mesures sucrées qui vont qui vont se
mettre en place et qui vont peser de
vous coupe un instant et on revient sur
ces mesures sucrées et peut-être sur ce
nouvel équilibre après les décisions du
Conseil constitutionnel mais d'abord on
retourne sur le terrain avec Vincent
rozeron qui avec un sénateur un sénateur
socialiste Patrick Kammer tiens
demande-lui parce que j'aime bien cette
expression de Marie-Cécile Renaud s'il y
a pas un début de gueule de bois
alors je vais lui poser la question
notre joie il semble plateau nous
demande s'il y a pas un début de gueule
de bois dans cette manifestation qu'en
pensez-vous avec ce que vous voyez
actuellement oh vous savez on sait très
bien que cette manifestation va pas
changer le cours des choses
malheureusement sur la réforme des
retraites mais il faut être là cette loi
est aujourd'hui validée compris par le
Conseil constitutionnel donc c'est la
loi de la République ça nous empêche pas
de la considérer comme toujours injuste
et un populaire et on le voit encore
aujourd'hui donc on continue et nous
aurons d'autres combats à venir
notamment sur le pouvoir d'achat qui va
être un élément majeur dans les semaines
à venir manifestement les Français n'en
peuvent plus aujourd'hui de vivre moins
bien qu'il y a encore quelques temps
donc oui cette cette manifestation et
aujourd'hui
un élément de continuité la terre
syndicale nous a montré le chemin elle
va perdurer encore sur d'autres combats
et nous à gauche et bien on a été
rassemblé et moi je suis aujourd'hui
triste pour mes collègues députés moi
sénateur on a eu le débat au Sénat sur
cette loi des Ret je suis triste pour
mes collègues députés qui manifestement
vont se faire voler un débat
démocratique dans 48 heures oui alors
vous pensez que dans 48 heures il n'y
aura pas de débats qu'on attend
forcément le train le train je pense que
Madame Brown privé la présidente de
l'Assemblée va opposer le fameux article
40 de la Constitution pour empêcher
qu'il y a un débat sur cette cette
abrogation potentielle des de la loi sur
les retraites faut faire attention à
force de bâillonner le Parlement et bien
c'est le peuple qui se sent bâillonné et
il y a un risque de débordement donc le
gouvernement doit entendre cette
aspiration finalement un fonctionnement
démocratique de nos institutions c'est
l'important c'est d'être là de montrer
que vous êtes ça va être quoi du coup la
suite maintenant c'est que c'est sur une
autre texte c'est montrer que voilà vous
vous serez toujours présent oui alors
vous savez les autres textes qu'à venir
c'est l'immigration si jamais un jour il
est inscrit à l'heure du jour des deux
assemblées le pouvoir d'achat je vous en
ai parlé et puis il y a quand même des
échéances électorales qui arrivent en
septembre il y aura les sénatori le
Sénat a montré tout tout son poids toute
sa force ces derniers mois et depuis
même d'ailleurs plusieurs années
maintenant et donc c'est une chance
importante qu'il faudra regarder avec
beaucoup d'attention pour les
commentateurs que vous êtes et derrière
question sur l'unité de la nude sur
cette unité vous avez là vous avez
l'impression d'avoir réussi à avoir
réussi à tenir ensemble tout au long de
cette réforme oui on l'a vu sur les
retraites l'Union est un combat elle ne
peut pas être entre guillemets
l'hégémonie d'un sur les autres donc il
faut trouver les voies de l'équilibre
c'est l'enjeu pour la nuque pour exister
demain et moi je crois en tant que
socialiste que le PS doit retrouver
cette force centrale parce que je crois
que seul le PS est capable de ramener la
gauche au couloir très bien merci
beaucoup Patrick
voici pour l'interview de Patrick kaner
sénateur socialiste qui disait voilà le
but aujourd'hui c'est d'être dans la rue
même si il n'y croit pas beaucoup pour
la suite de la CC7 séquence comme on dit
de la réforme des retraites
[Musique]
parce qu'on disait il le dit lui-même il
faut être là
vous voyez il y a
[Musique]
qui se met déjà en place pour le premier
septembre
expliquez-moi ça parce que oui certains
manifestent mais la loi est passée et
maintenant il faut pouvoir la mettre en
place entre en vigueur c'est quoi le
premier septembre la machine est en
route donc maintenant il faut que
l'administration suive et là ça chauffe
si je puis dire j'ai rencontré la
semaine dernière Renault Villard qui est
le patron de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse la CNAV c'est la
principale caisse c'est celle de des
retraités du régime général et donc lui
était confiant alors il travaille il
rage-pied mais il dit tout sera prêt
tout sera prêt dès le 1er septembre pour
appliquer la réforme pourtant c'est un
énorme défi d'organisation imaginez il
faut former les agents à toutes ces
toutes ces nouvelles règles donc ils
sont tous informés enfin ils ont
beaucoup sont en formation il faut
adapter les systèmes d'information les
systèmes
et donc il y a aussi la rédaction des
décrets certains s'inquiétaient s'il y a
beaucoup de décrets d'applications qui
doivent être rédigées et certains
s'inquiétaient de savoir que
pensait que peut-être ne serait pas
pris en temps et heure et que donc ça
retarderait la réforme et bien non a
priori c'est bon les caisses de retraite
travaillent avec l'administration pour
que
non seulement les décrets soient
légalement applicables et juridiquement
bien ficelé mais aussi applicable
techniquement sur le terrain donc a
priori renovillard dans le patron de la
CNAV disait que tout serait prêt pour le
1er septembre alors ils ont dopé leurs
équipes effectivement ils ont recruté
vous dites que il y a des Français qui
appellent ou qui demandent est-ce que je
peux partir en fait c'est pas forcément
très clair donc il faut aider les
Français qui vont avoir affaire à ce
nouveau ce nouveau fonctionnement et en
plus le mettre en place le
fonctionnement ils ont eu un gros pic
d'appel au moment de la de l'annonce de
la réforme là maintenant ça ça retombe
un peu ça se calme parce que là ils font
des débats en ce moment des départs de
gens qui sont encore sous l'ancienne
législation mais néanmoins ils ont dopé
leurs équipes ils ont recruté 500
personnes enfin non ils ont ils vont
recruter 500 personnes ils ont déjà
recruté 200 en février par anticipation
et ils ont doublé leur augmenter leur
budget informatique qui maintenant va
atteindre 700 millions d'euros donc ils
ont les moyens ils ont mis les moyens et
pour répondre aux Français dont certains
sont très anxieux nous distillent
parfois même un petit peu nerveuse si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire un petit
peu agressif un petit peu tendu au
téléphone mais bon en même temps il
paraît que ça n'est pas propre à la
réforme des retraites qu'on constate
dans tous les services publics que ce
serait plutôt une un état des lieux post
covid ça serait lié au poste
des civilisations mais c'est d'autres
sujets les chansons
anxieux et angoissé ce qu'on peut
comprendre mais donc pour leur répondre
et bien il y a le simulateur en ligne où
l'on peut je ne sais pas si vous l'avez
fait mon cher Thibault mais quelques
jours
parce que ça permet de faire des choix
de vie de décision vous voyez si vous
voulez passer à mi-temps quel impact sur
la retraite si vous voulez travailler
d'avantage vous voyez c'est un outil qui
est très intéressant sur le site
Assurance Retraite on peut regarder ses
droits voir sa reconstitution de sa
carrière c'est pas la peine d'attendre
la veille du jour de du départ en
retrait pour s'assurer que tous les
trimestres sont bien répertoriés puis
c'est amusant parce que vous voyez que
l'administration c'est beaucoup de
choses et vous allez pouvoir compléter à
partir du mois de novembre vous pourrez
compléter votre carrière donc ça les
aidera à reconstituer bien les carrières
et sinon bien sûr
l'Assurance Retraite répond au téléphone
il y a un numéro court le 39 60 qui est
un numéro gratuit qui permet de se
renseigner mais il y a pas que la CNAV
il y a aussi par exemple la Gire Carco
qui est la retraite complémentaire là du
à partir du 17 du 17 juin du 17 au 23
juin ils font ce qu'ils appellent les
rendez-vous de la retraite tous les ans
c'est un rendez-vous ou des dizaines de
milliers de conseillers sont à votre
disposition vous pouvez appeler vous
renseigner sur votre retraite ou futur
retraite
voilà et puis
vous êtes en train de me faire du
service ciel c'est comme ça qu'on dit
oui
alors si vous vous
demandez mais que vous n'avez
[Musique]
au début de ce direct ça se remplit
c'est quand même ça se remplit par
rapport à ce qu'on a vu en arrivant
assez tôt aujourd'hui mais en tout cas
on a l'impression par rapport aux autres
manifestations qu'on a fait et notamment
celle qui partaient aussi d'invalides
puisque du coup on sait à peu près à
quoi ça ressemble une manif qui partait
valide avec beaucoup de monde une
manifestation excusez-moi je suis parti
d'invalides avec beaucoup de monde
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que c'est
plus clairsemé même si même si il y a
quand même du monde voyez sur les images
qui se de Julien Leclerc qui sont avec
moi et c'est vrai qu'on a senti alors
pas forcément une résignation et tout à
l'heure on était avec l'oscillateur
socialiste Patrick kaner qui nous disait
justement oui il faut être là parce que
c'est la fin c'est la fin de la séquence
c'est la fin de la séquence il faut
qu'on soit là à ce moment-là pour
montrer qu'on n'existe encore et qu'on
est toujours là même si ils ne se font
plus trop d'illusions sur la suite de ce
combat il prépare en fait plutôt la
suite voilà ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure Patrick Kader en substance on va
continuer à avancer nous dans cette
manifestation on va bientôt arriver au
point de rassemblement parce qu'en fait
chaque partie politique assez petit
point de rassemblement tout au long de
cette manifestation et nous allons
arriver bientôt à celui de la France
insoumise où nous allons poser des
questions à des élus qui seront sur
place
bonjour bonjour Thibault en chef adjoint
au service société du Figaro en charge
des questions de sécurité notamment on
commence comme souvent par un point
chiffre alors combien de personnes
étaient attendues dans la rue
aujourd'hui les chiffres d'hier là je
vous demande de prévisions alors les
prévisions depuis ce weekend en fait les
services de renseignement estimaient
qu'il y avait entre 400 et 600 000
personnes qui
pouvaient se rendre dans les défilés de
de d'aujourd'hui c'est entre guillemets
un niveau qui attaque assez élevé après
6 mois de mobilisation
qui reste moyen c'est-à-dire entre le
pic de du 31 janvier où il y avait
millions de personnes à 1,2,3 on va dire
million de personnes et le creux du du
13 avril où il y avait 380 000 personnes
c'était à peu près entre les deux donc
on s'attendait à une journée une journée
moyenne qui pouvait ressembler un petit
peu à un début de mois d'avril d'accord
et alors les premières remontées de
terrain parce que c'est toujours pareil
la manifestation parisienne à lui en ce
moment cet après-midi mais on a des
chiffres de ce matin en région et oui et
les chiffres en région sont bien dans ça
de ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
et en tout cas en deçà de ce qui avait
prévu les les services les services de
renseignement en gros le dernier
pointage d'ailleurs qui a été réalisé
par fig data mais mais en évidence 115
000 personnes ce qui veut dire que au
regard des de de du 1er mai par exemple
on est à presque trois fois moins quand
même
on était à 300 000 personnes le 1er mai
et là à cette heure là à cette heure là
14h d'ailleurs qu'en fait on est
vraiment sur alors où l'on parle trois
fois moins quasiment trois fois une
personne dans la rue que le 1er mai ce
qui est un ce qui est pas ce qui est pas
génial et alors je pourrai avoir discuté
avec des des analystes du ministère de
l'intérieur on attendait des villes où
ça allait bouger secouer pas mal comme à
Toulouse où ils attendaient 12000
vous voulez dire euh
bouger des grosses des gros mouvements
vous me parlez de la violence
secouer c'est du monde dans la rue du
monde dans la rue du monde dans la rue
et alors à Toulouse on attendait 12000
et là on est plutôt à 6000 la moitié
idem il y a des villes c'est incroyable
enfin Montpellier par exemple il y a
2000 on vient de me dire il y a 2500
personnes qui étaient à Montpellier
enfin ce chiffre préfecture de police
2500 personnes c'est 10 fois moins que
le 7 mars dernier quand il y avait le
pic du mouvement c'est à dire qu'on est
alors Laurent Berger disait bon c'est un
match qui est en train de se terminer il
y en a d'autres qui disent que c'est le
chant du signe en tout cas je ne sais
pas quel est le vocable qu'on peut
mettre pour définir ces situations mais
on est face à une décélération certaine
et en fait même d'usure qui est
quasiment palpable 6 mois après le début
de ce mouvement de grogne bande
descendante de cette courbe de
participation vous me disiez et je sais
quelle ville vous allez me citer
Christophe que au début du mouvement les
petites et moyennes villes faisaient
grimper le nombre de manifestants est-ce
que c'est toujours le cas ça c'est un
peu tassé cette histoire alors non non
enfin là ça se passe encore
j'ai changé un petit peu
me parler de guérir dans la Creuse
mais ce n'est pas une je n'ai pas eu le
chiffre une maison secondaire à guérir
généralement il y a des petits des
petits endroits tests comme ça mais ils
ont changé et par exemple la foi est à
Montélimar on attendait assaut de de
gilets jaunes finalement on est sur des
proportions de 1000 un millier de
manifestants c'est à dire des des des
choses qui sont quasiment c'est pas
erzaast quoi mais c'est très très peu
donc sur ce genre de ville c'est ce que
fait d'ailleurs le figata et vous pouvez
retrouver on a un pourcentage par
rapport à la population évidemment et
dans ces petites villes ville moyenne il
y avait un pourcentage de la population
présent dans les manifestations très
important mais oui par exemple il y
avait je me souviens on avait cité par
le passé enfin pas si loin tant que ça
mais je crois au pays de la mobilisation
Verdun avec 10000 manifestants 10 000
manifestants à Versailles qui a
Montpellier ou Toulouse aujourd'hui
donc on est vraiment on est vraiment là
sur des sur des mobilisations
importantes et et c'est vraiment sur
tous les Français avec les gilets jaunes
qui avait quand même continué c'est de
rameuter des forces via les réseaux
sociaux notamment il y a Olivier roux
qu'on appelle sur les réseaux qui se
s’appelle olive olive d'accord figure
historique du mouvement
appelait à ce qu'on sème la pagaille etc
et finalement bon
les gilets jaunes sont un peu sont un
peu panneaux
au ministère de l'intérieur on vous dit
votre papier qu'il est encore une très
forte envie de manifestation c'est vrai
ça il y a toujours des irréductibles des
gens qui veulent manifester qui ne
veulent rien lâcher de toute façon les
sondages sont là pour le enfin
certainement pas autant que vos premiers
jours mais il y a encore des sondages
qui administrent
les défaits concrets il y a 57% des
Français qui sont encore hostiles à
cette style mais à ce moment très fort
pour la plupart
et voilà c'est à dire qu'il y a toujours
il y a toujours un un noyau de personnes
qui ne veulent pas se résoudre parmi les
Français en colère il y en a toujours
certains qui pensent possible de revenir
sur ce retour de l'âge légal de 64
maintenant à 62 ans comme avant il y en
a qui n'en démorent pas et continuons à
battre le pavé jusqu'au bout ce sont les
Ultra en général c'est ça qui est
potentiellement
parfois source de d'inquiétude parce que
c'est dans ces fins de mouvement dans
ces queues de comètes que ce
cristalliser une colère de la
désespérance et des actions coup de
poing je vous ai lu également vous dites
on manifeste plutôt contre Macron
finalement contre la réforme des
retraites
la réforme des retraites reste
évidemment l'emballage je dirais mais
derrière il y a évidemment
le pouvoir d'achat il y a l'inflation il
y a les zones il y a tout le côté cette
France un peu cette transpérité qu'on
oublie
je vous écoute Christophe j'ai
l'impression que vous me parlez des
gilets jaunes mais il y a les gilets
jaunes mais c'est à dire qu'en fait il y
a eu je pense que le l'esprit gilet
jaune a percolé quelque part dans la
dans la société et et il faut bien
comprendre que les gilets jaunes ne sont
pas venus nulle part c'est qu'il y avait
comme une situation de fait et qui était
qui était là il y a encore en 2018-2019
et elle n'est pas à mon sens réglé
ça se voit dans les en tout cas dans les
dans les slogans qui sont encore
qui émaillent un peu les cortège donc on
n'est pas forcément que sur les
retraites à 64 ans alors ça reste
électrique notamment avec la proximité
de ce qui pourrait se passer jeudi à
l'Assemblée c'était d'une certaine
manière pour le ministère de l'Intérieur
qui prépare ce genre de manifestation le
dernier grand moment parce qu'il y a ces
deux journées aujourd'hui et jeudi
souviens qu'il y avait le 49-3 qui avait
été brandi comme un déni démocratie afin
de d'essayer de de capter encore de de
faire en sorte que les la contestation
sera reste vive et il faut toujours
trouver des des relais des des mots des
tas des fautes des fanions des dates
clés et effectivement on est à 48 heures
donc de cette de cet examen en séance à
l'Assemblée de du projet du texte liotte
qui vise à revenir sur ce report à 64
ans on précise que il y a des chances
qu'il ne soit même jamais débattus mais
il y a il y a une possibilité jeudi mais
vous le faites vous faites très bien de
souligner Thibault parce que c'est vrai
qu'a priori l'article 40 devrait
empêcher
mais c'est l'épouvantail en tout cas qui
est brandi et c'est en tout cas ou en
tout cas le
quelque chose qui est de nature à
essayer de fédérer encore la colère de
faire de bouche à bouche je dirais avec
ce mouvement qui commence à être un peu
moribond et alors ce que disent les
services de renseignement c'est que vu
qu'on est sur cette ligne du temps
Emmanuel Macron parce qu'on va essayer
d'écouter vous le voyez nous Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui il doit sûrement essayer
de capitaliser sur ce qui peut se passer
je dis à l'Assemblée nationale de de
l'entendre parce qu'ils sont moins de la
caméra
[Musique]
se rapprocher de temps de son micro à
son roseron et Julien Leclerc qui sont
les envoyer
vous inquiétez pas je vous coupe dans un
instant Christophe parce que je suis sûr
qu'ils vont réussir à capter Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a des gens qui ne vont
plus aller manifester ce sont les jeunes
apparemment alors vous parlez du 49-3 le
soir ou le 49-3 était déposé je me
souviens j'y étais je sortais de
l'assemblée et je suis passé place de la
Concorde d'un seul coup les jeunes se
sont réunis les jeunes étaient à un
moment au rendez-vous et on arrivait à
ce scénario que redoutant l'exécutif qui
est celui de d'une cristallisation et
d'une généralisation de la contestation
à un mouvement de jeunesse qui devient
généralement plus contrôlable ou
difficilement contrôlable dans la mesure
où
quand il y a les jeunes il y a eu des
incidents par le passé notamment avec la
mort de malikosikine et pour ici c'est
un scénario extrêmement dur à
appréhender le ce qui s'est passé c'est
que pour les policiers et ça peut tout à
fait faire changer de dimension le
mouvement et que ce mouvement prenne une
ampleur politique différente bien sûr
vous pourriez avoir par exemple imagine
dans le cas de mort d'un jeune et bien
ok Emmanuel Macron qui prend la parole
et qui s'exprime en disant nous allons
faire une pause dans ce processus de
réforme de retraite c'est tout à fait
possible c'est d'ailleurs c'est pour
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il y avait
la mort de malikosikine étudiant en 1986
à Paris qui avait encore tous les
esprits parce que on sait très bien que
un drame une tragédie de cette nature là
fait peut faire basculer un mouvement
social et pas forcément dans le sens que
souhaiterait l'exécutif ça c'est une
c'est une chose mais à partir du moment
où il y a pas eu de il y a pas eu de on
va dire de de de de
ramphi d'occupation de fac il y a pas eu
de mouvement
Christophe ça y est on l'a avec une
belle image et on l'écoute
monsieur Darmanin m'annonce la présence
des provocateurs ou de je sais pas qui
pardon les services de renseignement des
charrues vous les fréquentez vous l'ont
dit à vous non vous n'en savez rien donc
le colportez pas des nouvelles sur
lesquels pardon monsieur je vous parle
comme ça parce que après on vient tous
fous alors moi je lui réponds et on fait
et vous savez quoi il paraît que le Père
Noël va venir avec deux martiens
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez monsieur
mais le micro il lui a répondu mais eux
mais on est on crée des événements qui
n'existent pas ou bien quand ils
existent on n'est pas capables de les
évaluer sérieusement voilà je proteste
contre cette manière de faire
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
défendre le droit à la retraite et
encore à 62 ans c'est ça qu'on est en
train de faire pas de s'occuper des
clowns de Darmanin et de sa mise en
scène de son cauchemar préféré
c'est une journée de lutte et il y a que
la lutte qui paye c'est si on se bat pas
qui se passera rien alors bon est-ce
qu'il y a moins de monde dans la rue je
sais pas moi on m'a dit que si on avait
toujours autant alors on va voir
nous allons voir parce que c'est d'abord
au syndicat c'est eux qui ont mené la
lune jusque là c'est eux qui l'ont
organisé nous nous avons fonctionné
comme à une force de de renfort nous
avons appelé au manifestations nous
avons amené des sous à la crise de grève
nous avons distribué des millions de
tracks fait des centaines de réunions
publiques bon voilà quel a été notre
rôle et essayer de mobiliser tout ce
qu'on pouvait chaque fois qu'il y avait
une manif mais ceux qui ont pris les
décisions c'est à dire convoquer les
journées d'action
décider ou pas de la coordination des
mouvements de grève ce sont les
directions syndicales donc on va d'abord
voir ce qu'il nous propose et en
fonction de ça je pense que on prendra
position il y a des questions
étant des jours répondrai je vous
promets mais pas là si on est dans on
est dans la bataille pour les retraites
je veux pas moi-même desservir ma cause
apparemment
bon tout le monde a dit je sais pas
pourquoi ah c'est le RN qui progresse
qui progrès pour faire un foutu sondage
les seuls qui arrivent en tête c'est la
nuit pêche donc apparemment si vous êtes
il y a oui mais Dieu donc bien pourquoi
faut l'être et ben merci de le dire
monsieur il faut donc être une et je
pense que c'est une contribution
normalement la plus directe à la lutte
si vous voulez qu'elle continue sous une
forme c'est de mettre une raclée à
Monsieur Macron aux prochaines élections
nous on est des démocrates on croise ça
aux élections voilà
c'est pareil la gauche de l'autre la
faute à qui
la faute vous allez tout de suite me
fâcher avec la moitié du monde là mais
bon nous on était disponible pour le
faire ensemble mais on a été très
handicapé pendant une longue période par
la façon de fonctionner de Monsieur
Philippe Martinez qui vous en souvenez
c'en est pris à moi était absolument
hostile à toute sans qu'on n'est jamais
compris pourquoi alors bon maintenant le
temps un peu le temps a beaucoup changé
il y a une ambiance qui est plus
favorable avec avec la CGT bon qu'on
soit pas d'accord ça peut arriver mais
on n'est pas obligé de s'engueuler en
public
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour un joli Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Christophe ça a l'air un peu agacé hein
il a un peu tensé un collègue j'ai
l'impression qu'il s'est vite repris
pardon monsieur je vous parle comme ça
parce que il parlait justement c'est un
peu votre spécialité pas de casser
évidemment mais de nous parler des
casseurs on lui a demandé il pourrait y
avoir des casseurs dans cette
manifestation il y en a pas c'est une
manière de faire c'est de ministère de
l'Intérieur qui agite cet épouvantail
donc là on est on est je je c'est un peu
fort de café pour être franc parce que
quand il s'agit pas de de défendre les
torby le ministre de l'Intérieur
Darmanin ou ses successeurs mais il est
clair que
dire dire que c'est une clonerie comme
il le dit il dit que Darmanin dit que
c'est une clonerie de dire qu'il y a des
casseurs dans Paris ou dans les
manifestations
c'est quand même avoir la mémoire un peu
courte juste pour mémoire
le le 23 le 23 mars dernier il y a eu
quand même 550 policiers et gendarmes
blessés dans une seule journée de
manifestation donc là on est plus du
tout dans la dans la country il y a eu
des sous-préfectures des préfectures des
commissariats des hôtels de ville qui
ont été vandalisés à partir du 16 mars
et les et les jours et les et les
épisodes suivants jusqu'à la fin mai en
fait on est véritablement dans une on a
eu une flambée de violence que personne
ne peut contester si ce n'est peut-être
monsieur Monsieur Mélenchon et et et en
plus
généralement ce que ce que dit le ce que
disent des analystes du ministère de
l'Intérieur se vérifie veut dire que
quand le ministère de l'Intérieur là par
exemple il nous disent qu'il y aura nous
avaient prévu un noyau dur de 100 à 150
personnes à Nantes qui pouvait agréger
entre 500 et 600 émeutiers potentiel
à peu près autant à Brest à Dijon à
Strasbourg et autant à Lyon on se rend
compte aujourd'hui que il y a des
incidents à Lyon que les incidents il y
a eu des incidents
de projectiles sur les forces de l'ordre
on n'est pas encore dans la clunerie non
plus je crois il y a eu une donc obligé
en centre-ville une fois encore la
grande lassitude de la population et des
commerçants ripost et affrontement avec
gaz lacrymogène dans dans l'autre sens
il y a eu à Nantes des tensions aussi en
centre-ville c'est à dire qu'on est
absolument pas dans dans un schéma
belphégorien où on inventerait des
casseurs qui n'existent pas pour faire
peur aux gens ils existent vraiment je
veux dire si tous les commerçants de
France et de Navarre se claquent mur et
mettent des panneaux en bois sur le
passage des des
manifestants c'est pas par hasard et si
des milliers de personnes s'habillent en
noir à travers le pays
pour semer la pagaille en début de
manifestation c'est certainement pas des
agents double
avec ce parapluie ça c'est pas
inintéressant ce parapluie ça veut dire
des choses c'est un symbole de
ralliement c'est ça souvent les
black-box se réunissent sous ses
parapluies
multicolores alors on voit d'ailleurs
arriver une voilà alors les les
parapluies là on a effectivement comme
une espèce de mise en place du du blaspo
du dispo Black Bloc classique à savoir
la grande la grande comment bâche
rigide ou semi-rigide généralement
à huile enfin en toile c'est en toile en
toile qui puisse
rejeter un petit peu le les projections
de dos 6 en face au canon à eau se
protéger aussi déjà de grenades
lacrymogène et puis et puis se servir de
s'en servir comme une paroi pour de
l'autre côté jeter des projectiles sur
les sur les forces de l'ordre c'est à
dire que on est sur la l'amorce de ce
qui pourrait être un black bloc faut
savoir que dans Paris il y en a à peu
près un millier qui était annoncé par le
par le préfet de police qui n'est pas
lui non plus un adepte de l'ordre
permanente on en parle dans un instant
Christophe parce qu'on va sur le terrain
député Coquerel est avec Sophie ravin
elle notre journaliste du Figaro
spécialiste de la gauche grand reporter
au service politique avec Vincent
roseron Vincent vous avez la main avec
donc notre journaliste et le député de
la France insoumise
oui effectivement ah alors quelqu'un
vient de passer devant pardon
excusez-moi bien de passer devant
à qui je vais laisser le micro pour
arriver Eric Coquerel puisque c'est
c'est son domaine
je pense alors moi j'ai une première
question pour vous Éric Coquerel vous
êtes à la tête de la commission des
finances se joue évidemment aujourd'hui
le déclenchement de l'article 40 la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il y
a une brune Pivet peut vous interroger
le le la logique la tradition c'est
qu'elle vous interroge on connaît votre
avis sur l'article 40 elle peut aussi
décider de le de le déclencher
d'elle-même passant outre vos votre
responsabilité qu'est-ce que vous en
diriez dans ce cas là
va dans les deux cas je dirais que c'est
une pratique constante qui est en train
d'être détruite tu as un problème alors
déjà si elle m'interroge pas ça sera une
fois de plus quelque chose de totalement
inédit
vraiment inédit dans l'histoire
parlementaire de la 5e République
président de la commission des finances
de soi passeries par la par la présence
de l'Assemblée sur un amendement ça ça
sera déjà une première problématique et
puis la deuxième ça sera si elle décide
de rendre irrecevable la restitution le
rétablissement de l'article 1 voilà
parce que ça ça n'a jamais été fait non
plus pour la SEC depuis la série début
de la cinquième puis on n'a jamais rendu
irrecevable un amendement qui restitue
un texte qui lui a été déclaré recevable
et je rappelle qu'il a été déclaré
recevable par mois mais par elle aussi à
travers le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale donc elle se contredirait
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
s'agit d'une forme vous dites qu'il
s'agit d'une forme d'obstruction
parlementaire c'est une forme qui s'en
prend la démocratie parlementaire aux
droits d'initiative parlementaires au
droit de l'opposition parce que si
progressivement la jurisprudence a fait
en sorte qu'il y ait une application
souple de l'article 40 sur les
propositions de loi c'est justement au
nom l'initiative appartement
parlementaire s'ils font ça c'est ça qui
ne mettent par terre et je souhaite
bonne chance pour les futurs
propositions loi est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que les Français finalement
sont attentifs à ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que être impacté
d'une d'une autre par l'action du
gouvernement ou de la majorité provisée
après présidentielle au sein de
l'assemblée
les gens viennent me voir en disant
tenez bon sur l'article 40 je parle pas
seulement dans la manifestation là donc
je pense qu'ils ont bien compris qu'il y
a un problème démocratique qui se pose
voilà au moins les macronistes ont
réussi à populariser l'article 40 comme
un élément pour justement empêcher le
vote en réalité c'est ça le problème de
fond qui se posait là l'article 40 là il
est pas il est pas brandi au nom de
respecter la question la recevabilité de
manière théorique il est brandi parce
que les le camp macroniste est
minoritaire et qu'il ne veut pas aller
jusqu'à votre salle problème est-ce que
vous avez pas le sentiment aussi qu'il
s'agit que d'une mesure un petit peu qui
vient suivre la surconflictualité
décidée par Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
appliquer au sein de l'assemblée par les
parlementaires dont vous êtes du groupe
insoumis là vous êtes extraordinaire je
vous rappelle que depuis maintenant un
an
les macronistes utilisent absolument
tout toutes les règles à mon avis
d'ailleurs de manière parfois
anticonstituelle pour ne pas voter ça a
été vrai sur le budget 10 49-3 ça a été
vrai sur le projet de réforme de
retraite et là c'est vrai que l'article
40 alors expliquez que c'est à cause de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça serait un peu fort
quand même ok à cause de certaines
décisions de certains propos tenus dans
l'assemblée de certains comportements
est-ce que vous avez eu le sentiment que
il y a des groupes dont le vôtre qui ont
mis de l'huile sur le feu où vous jugez
que c'est pour vous une défense de la
démocratie et mon sentiment c'est que je
connais peu de démocratie parlementaires
qui tient sans faire voter les
parlementaires voilà et ça c'est quand
même un problème de fond qui devrait à
mon avis rejoindre les démocrates bien
au-delà de la nupestre bien au-delà de
la gauche c'est ce qui explique
d'ailleurs qu'on fait chemin commun avec
l'iode c'est sur cette question
principalement est-ce que oui alors une
dernière application c'est est-ce que
vous aujourd'hui là vous vous y croyez à
ce que vendredi ça ne se passe pas comme
comme tout le monde le prédit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que que
finalement tout ça soit soit enterré
j'espère que jeudi parce que c'est jeudi
en fait je vous en prie comme quoi je
suis bien vos questions j'espère que
jeudi il y aura au moins des amendements
même symboliques qui quelque part
signifieront qu'on avait une assemblée
majoritairement contre ces réformes
voilà et je crois que après les deux
défaites que viennent vivre la MAC hier
la majorité sur la loi de règlement
c'est à la loi d'exécution des budgets
ils ont été battus deux fois je pense
que ça sera un nouveau symbole que dès
lors qu'on est sur des questions
budgétaires financières ou sociales ils
n'ont pas de majorité pour qu'un jour il
l'entende plutôt que mettre à mal la
démocratie parlementaire est-ce que
dernière question monsieur croquer vous
une nouvelle sentiment aujourd'hui que
cette manifestation a aussi pour
objectif de maintenir la tension et
l'attention en vue de ce qu'il pourrait
se passer cet été qu'est-ce que vous
voyez vous comme mouvement social pour
les prochains mois ça on verra bien moi
je pense que la question du pouvoir
d'achat la question de salaire qui suit
pas l'inflation ça reste des questions
qui vont être très fortes surtout que on
n'est pas du tout au bout de la crise
inflationniste donc ça pourrait très
bien rebondir sur ces questions là en
tout cas je pense pas que ça soit un
mouvement social battu voilà même si
jamais ils arrivaient à appliquer tous
les décrets d'application d'abord nous
on assume qu'on abrochera cette loi une
fois au pouvoir mais deuxièmement c'est
un mouvement qui a gagné dans son unité
la possibilité de croire qu'il est il
est possible de gagner d'avoir d'autres
victoires par la suite merci Monsieur
Goran et merci beaucoup Sophie ravidel
d'avoir été avec nous de devoir croiser
en manifestation on vous laisse
continuer de suivre cette belle sessions
merci Thibault c'est à vous merci
toujours avec Christophe Cornavin du
service société du Figaro on parlait de
ces Black Blocs potentiel alors et on
parlait de la déclaration de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui disait mais non il y en a
pas c'est une connerie c'est ça une
connerie bon surtout au début les
premières manifestations étaient très
calme ça s'est très bien passé il y a eu
un embrassement au mois de mars à peu
près notamment voilà on a été obligé par
la suite par exemple d'interdire la
venue de Charles III en France de
reporter la venue de Charleroi
exactement en fait c'est à dire que
pendant trois mois et en fait on a eu
les 8 premières journées nationales
d'action ont été plutôt plutôt calme
c'était une mer d'huile même on était
assez surpris on s'attendait avec des
enfants par exemple dans les
manifestations familiales et tout le
monde les forces de l'ordre les
premières s'attendaient à ce que ce qui
est un avis de bourrasque au tout début
de ce mouvement de grogne et au
contraire on était sur quelque chose de
relativement
bonne enfance j'aime pas ce mot mais en
tout cas calme et une manifestation sens
sans vague et tout d'un coup le 16 mars
évidemment
il est les forces de l'ordre se sont
trouvées tout d'un coup confrontés à des
actions extrêmement violentes d'ailleurs
d'une violence inhabituelle qui était en
dehors de tous les mots d'ordre
syndicaux et et ça a pris des formes que
l'on a vu de de de de de de course dans
Paris d'équiper nocturnes avec plus de
900 incendies une seule de poubelle et
de feu de dagues de vandalisme dans la
capitale pour pour un seul soir des
policiers blessés des attaques de
commissariat de bâtiments publics etc
enfin toutes les essais qui est arrivé
place de l'Opéra il me semble hein c'est
ça entre les places de la Bastille et de
l'Opéra il y avait eu pas mal de pas mal
d'exactions et ça avait ça avait scellé
en fait un virage dans le dans ce
mouvement qui était tout d'un coup
enflammé
le parcours aujourd'hui
invalide jusqu'à Place d'Italie comment
détermine un parcours est-ce que ça joue
ça et est-ce qu'il y a des endroits dans
Paris où il est plus facile de maîtriser
des mouvements de foule et les casseurs
ailleurs oui alors ça se détermine c'est
pas le préfet de police qui décide
généralement on est enfin les c'est une
c'est une négociation d'accord entre les
organisateurs donc les les
l'intersyndicales et les pouvoirs
publics et
l'idée c'est que la préfecture de police
essaie de d'orienter on va dire les les
cortèges pour éviter des zones sensibles
par exemple il est clair que la place de
la Concorde par exemple et proscrite à
une manifestation
on est près du Palais de l'Élysée on est
près du ministère de l'intérieur on est
sous les fenêtres de l'ambassade des
États-Unis d'Amérique on est de
l'Assemblée nationale de la Seine on est
à côté on est on est au Palais Bourbon
autant d'éléments qui font que le préfet
de police voit d'un très mauvais œil
l'idée d'organiser en revanche c'est
vrai qu'il y a pas eu une seule
manifestation qui s'est déroulée là-bas
il y a eu place de la Concorde faut se
souvenir le soir le soir du du 49 3 de
mémoire une un rassemblement spontanée
de plusieurs milliers de personnes
et ces jeunes qui avec réussi à marcher
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'assemblée avant d'être
repoussé
sur la rive droite de la de la scène et
après de s'égayer dans Paris en mettant
des en mettant des incendies des feux de
poubelles pendant des des des des des
des équiper un peu sauvages et
incontrôler mais généralement la
pression de police elle aime bien enfin
elle aime bien elle a il y a des
sentiers balisées je dirais entre
Bastille et République nation en
république etc là invalide pas d'Italie
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
maîtrisé on l'a déjà c'est un parcours
qui a eu lieu déjà en mars de mémoire et
mais avec des quand même des des points
des points d'attention notamment on sait
que ça va emprunter le boulevard du
Montparnasse et oui donc la symbolique
le symbolique pourquoi j'imagine que
vous devant votre écran d'ordinateur
vous savez de quoi on parle restaurant
de La Rotonde ou Emmanuel Macron avait
fêté sa son élection à la présidence
sa première place au premier tour et ça
oui ça voilà c'est la première place sa
première place et il est habitué des
lieux parce que il qui est allé on a vu
la rotonde plusieurs fois incendie deux
ou trois fois
quand on est sur ce parcours invalide
on est contraint le défilé passe par la
le Montparnasse avenue de Montparnasse
c'est donc devant la Rotondo qui a quand
même toujours de toute façon quoi que
l'on fasse dans Paris parce que Paris
est une ville ainsi faite on passe
souvent devant des des lieux à risque
des lieux sensibles mais là le préfet de
police a quand même de mémoire prévu
4000 hommes avec un fer de lance les
braves donc
logiquement il le disait ce matin chez
un de nos confrères il atteint il avait
l'air serein et il disait j'attends de
pied ferme les casseurs ce qui veut dire
que après le discours est déjà musclé je
sais que là j'ai reçu un tout à l'heure
un message et une demi-heure de la
préfecture de police qui me disait qu'à
14h30 donc juste au moment où le cortège
est branla il y avait déjà 27 contrôle
qui avait été faire en un mot du défilé
ce qui veut dire que
les forces de l'or sont très en alerte
aujourd'hui même si à moins de monde ou
peut-être moins de monde dans les rues
les policiers savent que eux les
casseurs eux sont au rendez-vous on ira
voir Vincent roseron dans un instant
pour qu'ils nous disent si tout se passe
bien ça a l'air sur les images très
calmes pour l'instant pour pour
l'instant vous expliquer dans votre
dernier papier qu'il y a des concours
sur certains sites un barème de points
pour pourquoi pour ceux qui arriveront à
mettre la France à l'arrêt je mets des
guillemets pour citer la CGT notamment
c'est ça ouais ouais il y a des il y a
des concours ça s'appelle le c'est en
fait il y a il y a un site qui appelle
à mettre le small
bazar le bazar le beans bordel comme
dirait d'autres voilà
la pagaille et en fait on continue sur
les synonymes comme ça je me concentre
allez-y et alors donc du coup pour donc
la zizanie est parfois le chaos et donc
du coup on est vraiment sur un concours
qui était lancé comme ça auprès des
internautes et auprès des gens qui vont
mettre donc qui vont passer à l'action
sur le terrain avec des des points alors
je me souviens là j'ai noté des huées ou
une casserole c'est un point
voilà une une
intervention d'un camarade pour limiter
la consommation énergétique en gros une
coupure de courant ça vaut trois points
une action plus violente conduisant au
départ d'une personnalité ça vaut quatre
points et en plus il y a un coefficient
multiplicateur en fonction de la
personne qui est gênée c'est à dire que
si
c'est le Président c'est un peu
particulier merci beaucoup pardon parce
que Guillaume Rocket nous rejoint et
puis on va laisser peut-être d'écouter
la première ministre elle sembler
répondre aux député le lot ah bon ben
voilà c'est raté dommage allons jeter
une oreille à l'Assemblée nationale
quand même
madame la Première ministre vous deviez
apaiser le pays vous continuez à jeter
de l'huile sur le feu tout ça n'est pas
responsable
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Présidente
pour le comprenez naissance
merci madame la Présidente ça a commencé
par des brimades sur mon poids en classe
je recevais des stylos des coups de
compas dans le dos je me prenais des
gifles et des insultes pendant 6 ans je
n'ai parlé à personne j'avais trop honte
j'avais trop peur et puis j'ai décidé
d'en finir j'ai acheté un litre d'alcool
à brûler je l'ai répondu sur mes
vêtements et je me suis mis le feu
j'avais 16 ans
ces mots sont ceux de Jonathan
du groupe René sens à l'Assemblée
nationale qui semble parler de ce sujet
d'actualité qui est le harcèlement
scolaire on a attendu juste avant
Bertrand pencher le président du groupe
hyote qui espère faire tomber cette
réforme des retraites dire à Elisabeth
borde qu'elle était irresponsable
Guillaume Rocket bonjour bonjour
directeur de la rédaction du Figaro
Magazine Guillaume vous pose la même
question qui a marqué Cécile Renaud tout
à l'heure et pourquoi faire cette
journée de manifestation
parce que il est trop difficile quand on
est un syndicat
et quand on est un soutien politique au
syndicat et je pense à la nupes de dire
nous avons perdu
de dire nous avons échoué de dire
cette opposition à la loi est un échec
et donc il y a cette espèce de baroud
d'honneur qui est une façon de pouvoir
clôturer ce chapitre
sans le dire sans dire la réalité c'est
la différence entre la CGT et Laurent
Berger Laurent Berger dit lui ok c'est
fini et je pense que la CGT fait une
grave erreur en ne voulant pas
reconnaître que ce combat est perdu
parce que quand vous êtes dans le déni
ça crée forcément des frustrations
voilà pour l'explication de Guillaume
Rocket qui lui semble dire que c'est la
guerre est-ce qu'il y a la moindre
chance que ce texte soit retoqué retiré
ou autre il y a 1% de chance non je ne
pense pas
je ne pense pas parce qu'encore une fois
le dispositif a été bien verrouillé on a
enlevé de de
la proposition de loi de l'alliotte le
la le l'élément qui pouvait remettre en
cause cette réforme et puis surtout je
pense que dans la tête des Français
cette réforme est passée et donc il y a
eu une forme de de résignation
certes pas de gaieté de coeur mais le
l'affluence moyenne pour ne pas dire
faible d'aujourd'hui montre que
c'est quelque chose qui maintenant
appartient aux paysages
les Français sont toujours contre mais
il ne descendent plus dans la rue
ça montre que oui bon bah c'est fait
quoi vous savez que moi c'est ma thèse
depuis le départ et pour une fois je me
suis pas trompé donc je suis content de
vous la retirer
je n'ai jamais cru à cette idée que la
France pouvait s'enflammer je n'ai
jamais cru à cette espèce de de discours
catastrophique que tenait une partie des
intellectuels et la gauche radicale en
disant la France va se lever tout
entière contre cette loi non moi ma
conviction c'est que les Français savent
depuis le départ qu'il va falloir
travailler plus longtemps bien sûr il
n'en n'ont pas envie et c'est normal à
moins d'avoir des métiers spécialement
passionnants on voit arriver la retraite
avec envie mais
néanmoins il y a un principe de réalité
et donc il y a une forme de de
dissociation des Français une partie de
de même disant on en veut pas et une
autre partie disant il va bien falloir y
passer je vais vous demander
l'impossible rapidement expliquer moi
très simplement la dernière infime
possibilité que ce texte on va retirer
je veux dire en gros que va-t-il se
passer jeudi à l'Assemblée nationale et
bien il y a ce ce
n'est pas simple non c'est pas simple en
plus j'ai peur de pas vous de pas vous
dire les choses de façon techniquement
exacte parce que moi ce que j'ai vu
c'est que dans le dans le c'est que le
gouvernement a fait en sorte que
l'alliotte ne puisse pas
présenter sa proposition de loi car elle
entraînerait une sorte de de
d'aggravation de la situation de
dépenses publiques et que théoriquement
quand vous faites une proposition de loi
elle doit être équilibrée les recettes
en face et donc là l'idée de repasser
avant de de à nouveau revenir à
l'interface à 62 ans bah ce serait un
coup après il y a des discussions
infinies pour dire mais non c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe parce que la
vérité c'est que l'économie n'est pas
réelle en face de ce de cette de ce
report de l'âge de la retraite mais
honnêtement et il va être tout à fait
sincère avec vous je suis même pas entré
dans le détail technique et du coup je
n'arrive pas à répondre précisément à
votre question c'est pas que j'ai pas
envie c'est pas que j'ai pas eu envie de
travailler c'est parce que je me suis
dit de toute façon ça ne se fera pas
exactement et même si il venait à y
avoir un vote cela ne passerait pas au
Sénat bon voilà
quelle image quand même
tout le monde est perdant et surtout on
ne votera jamais et ça c'est peut-être
un échec quand même Guillaume on ne
votera jamais sur ce texte oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est pour ou contre
mais on aime quand même le vote le choix
des électeurs et des députés oui on ne
votera pas pour ce texte parce que
l'histoire retiendra qu'il n'y avait pas
de majorité pour la voté pour le voter
pardon mais néanmoins il y a une forme
de vote puisque le gouvernement a engagé
sa responsabilité et que il n'y a pas eu
une majorité pour voter la censure or la
motion de censure elle avait bien lu sur
ce texte donc oui il y avait pas la
majorité pour le voter mais il n'y avait
pas non plus une majorité pour le pour
le refuser mais encore une fois je vois
ce que vous voulez dire mais bon les
Français attendent simplement oui non
l'âge de départ légal à 64 ans non oui
ben voilà et ben en l'occurrence ce
c'est passé je crois que les amateurs le
droit constitutionnel retiendront
longtemps
ces passes d'armes sur
le 49.3 était-il ou non légal le Conseil
constitutionnel de vitil ou non censuré
je pense que voilà le 47 1 le fait qu'il
y a eu un temps limité pour discuter de
de de cette proposition de loi je crois
que tous ces échos du Palais Bourbon
arrivent de façon très très
peut-être pas imprécise aux oreilles des
Français pour eux ben voilà le
gouvernement a voulu faire ça
il a voulu faire passer le texte
Emmanuel Macron il tenait il y a eu des
manifs et finalement c'est le
gouvernement qui est le dernier mot
comme les fois précédentes d'ailleurs
parce que l'histoire se rappelle et je
pense que c'est un des choses qu'il
faudra retenir c'est que le le
monde social le les représentants des
syndicats ne sont plus capables en
France de s'opposer à une mesure qui
leur déplaît ça a été vrai sur la
réforme de de du droit du travail au
début du quinquennat ça a été vrai sur
les ordonnances
prises par François Hollande ça a été
vrai aussi lorsque l'âge de la retraite
a été repoussé sous Nicolas Sarkozy ça
montre donc que finalement bah ces gens
font beaucoup de bruit ils ont une
capacité de nuisance réelle mais ils ne
peuvent pas s'opposer au choix d'une
majorité et je pense une majorité
parlementaire ou en tout cas une une
absence de majorité contre et je pense
que c'est une bonne chose parce que ça
s'appelle la démocratie
on va faire un bilan puisque vous me
dites que c'est probablement la dernière
on commence par le gouvernement
des soins qui a une fracture irréparable
entre le peuple et le pouvoir après
cette séquence est-ce que c'est vrai et
à quel point je pense pas que ce soit
vrai
c'est que le Figaro Magazine publie
chaque mois
son baromètre avec la cote de confiance
du président de la République et de la
première ministre Emmanuel Macron est
encore à en gros un petit tiers des
Français qui lui font confiance bien sûr
il a connu
donc
moi je ne pense que il y a une forme de
de lassitude qui est classique pour un
deuxième quinquennat mais je pense que
les Français en fait ne se sont pas
autant focalisés que cela sur la réforme
des retraites je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
préoccupation c'est l'inflation et là
pour le coup il voit bien que la
situation est difficile mais elle n'est
pas catastrophique vous savez que
l'INSEE a même dit que le pouvoir
d'achat n'avait pas baissé l'année
dernière
notamment grâce aux aides au chèque
énergie et autres mesures du
gouvernement donc je pense que cette
rupture elle est relative encore une
fois il y a eu une forme mais ça arrive
souvent moi qui fait ce métier depuis
quelques semaines il y a une forme
d'emballement médiatique si vous voulez
ou à force de répéter la même chose
surtout les plateaux les gens ont cru
que c'était la vérité et donc cette idée
que que la France était en train de
revivre en mai 68 ou une période de
révolutionnaire 95 de la c'était déjà
pas mal absolument mais la vérité c'est
qu'on a rien eu de tout ça sans paniquer
d'une certaine manière Emmanuel Macron
sans renvoyer Elizabeth borne sans
remaner son gouvernement sans dissoudre
sa cote de popularité remonte
s'en sort pas si mal oui il s'en sort
pas si mal parce que je pense qu'il a
habilement gérer cette réforme il a fait
quelque chose de réforme ou juste après
la réforme non la réforme aussi ah oui
vous trouvez oui parce que qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait bah il a fait ce que font
tous les présidents de la République en
tout cas tous ceux qui ont succédé au
général de Gaulle c'est-à-dire que il
envoie son premier ministre comme une
sorte de bouclier humain pour prendre
les coups pour servir de paratonnerre et
lui-même maintenant dit il est temps de
passer à la séquence suivante donc je
pense que c'était ça a été assez
habilement géré et il a été cohérent
avec lui-même dès lors que c'était
Elisabeth borne qui portait la réforme
il ne pouvait pas s'en séparer juste
après sinon ça voulait dire que lui-même
était opposé à cette réforme et ça
aurait été encore une fois incohérent
c'est 100 jours ça semble être une une
réussite alors il porte ça tout seul au
début il nous a dit Elisabeth borne doit
mener ses 100 jours qui
14 juillet c'est ça relancer le pays
après cette séquence tu fais ça tout
seul comme un grand Emmanuel Macron il
relance rien du tout c'est un peu tout
ça ces espèces de d'artifice de
communication oui mais non chaque
semaine on nous annonce beaucoup de
l'industrialisation
mais c'est la vérité c'est que ça va
prendre 25 ans hier il nous parle de
nous réapproprier notre histoire parce
qu'il était homo Saint-Michel la semaine
d'avant il disait qu'il y avait 100
jours pour faire des des relances sur
des thèmes qu'on a déjà oublié non la
vérité c'est que c'est juste pour
essayer de d'occuper un peu l'espace
médiatique parce que la nature hors du
vide mais mais sur le fond le président
de la République c'est parfaitement que
aujourd'hui il n'a pas de majorité pour
faire de grandes réformes et que donc
que sur tous les sujets que ce soit des
sujets économiques ou des sujets
régaliens comme l'immigration ben pour
l'instant il ne peut rien faire nous
sommes en direct qu'un 23 poursuivre
cette 14e peut-être dernière journée de
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites on fait un peu le bilan et on
passe à l'opposition la gauche d'abord
paris perdu parce qu'elle semble se
diviser désormais après une séquence qui
aurait dû la renforcer normalement la
lutte sociale contre la réforme des
retraites à gauche aurait dû tirer les
marrons du feu c'est pas vraiment le cas
alors oui mais elle ne sait pas diviser
sur son opposition à cette réforme parce
que le le globalement les socialistes
les écologistes c'est presque ça qu'il a
fait tenir ensemble la France insoumise
et le Parti communiste ils étaient tous
opposés à cette réforme et pourtant vous
avez raison bien qu'ils aient été en
phase avec l'opinion majoritaire dans le
pays ils sortent affaiblis de cette
séquence pourquoi et bien parce que
derrière un Jean-Luc Mélenchon
tonitruant vitupérant bordélisant
l'Assemblée nationale ils avaient dit
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
nous allons faire rempart de notre corps
et cette réforme ne passera pas et bien
le résultat des courses c'est que si
elle est passée et donc ils sont
profondément des critiques et le
rassemblement national a été beaucoup
plus intelligent en disant nous sommes
opposés à cette réforme et puis point et
puis ils sont pas apparus dans les
manifestations d'abord parce que les
syndicats avaient expliqué qu'il n'y
était pas allé bienvenus mais je pense
que si que politiquement ça ça avantagé
Marine Le Pen puisque de toute façon
elle savait bien que cette réforme
allait passer et donc elle a elle a en
quelque sorte
poser une sorte de jalon en disant nous
on était contre mais si vous voulez
revenir là-dessus bah il faut voter pour
nous mais pour le reste ça sert à rien
de de s'agiter et de et de et de taper
sur des casseroles à chaque visite
ministérielle
il y a une petite demi-heure je pense il
nous dit les sondages sortent sur les
élections européennes et la gauche
arriverait en tête la gauche unie
elle n'a peut-être pas tout perdu la
gauche non la gauche n'a pas tout perdu
dans la mesure où effectivement elle ne
sait pas divisée sur ce sujet
elle peut arriver en tête aux
européennes si il y a une liste unique
mais à priori
ça semble pas être le souhait de tous
les socialistes encore moins des
écologistes et donc je crois que
oui je crois que que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
là
exprime plus un souhait qu'il ne décrit
une réalité c'est à dire que cette cette
liste unique ben c'était le ça a été le
ressort de de la nupes aux dernières
élections mais la gauche n'a pas été
majoritaire pour autant et donc je pense
qu'on n'est pas
on n'est pas à l'abri de surprise et de
et de de de de de trajectoire un peu
personnelle il y a un certain nombre de
gens notamment en partie socialistes qui
se disent Emmanuel Macron se
représentera pas peut-être qu'il y a
maintenant une place pour une gauche
réformiste
ce week-end et ils ont quelque
personnalités de de valeur et je pense
que
l'alliance avec la nupes l'alliance avec
la France insoumise pardon au sein de la
nupestre c'était une sorte de de choix
par défaut c'est-à-dire avec un constat
qui était celui que Emmanuel Macron
occupait tout l'espace central de gauche
et de droite et que donc il n'y avait de
place que pour une opposition radicale
et et et ils ont tiré les conclusions
avec ces listes uniques pour les
législatives en revanche à la pour les
prochaines échéances cette situation
sera différente puisqu'emmanuel Macron
se représente pas on a parlé de la
gauche vous ne m'avez parlé du
rassemblement national et la droite
perdante elle aussi
incapable de donner soit une image
rassemblée soit une cohérence
idéologique oui perdante parce que
diviser et la cohérente non et pas
cohérente c'est vrai puisque une
majorité des députés LR où ont voté
cette réforme continuent à la soutenir
mais une minorité est forcément c'est
toujours les minorités qu'on écoute
parce que ce sont les plus les plus
bruyantes et les plus agitées
une minorité à
refuser cette cette réforme et du coup
la droite est apparue comme étant en
quelque sorte immature or je pense que
c'était un vrai une vraie une vraie
erreur alors on va essayer d'être un peu
positif 1 les républicains n'ont pas
explosé c'est à dire que même ceux qui
n'ont pas voté la réforme n'ont pas
claqué la porte du parti et puis deux je
pense que non on les a pas renvoyé même
si on les a écartés des instances
dirigeantes et puis je pense que de
toute façon vous savez c'est une une
séquence qui va se terminer et et les
gens oublient vite donc certes c'était
pas brillant mais c'était pas non plus
la catastrophe absolue pour les
républicains on peut faire le bilan des
syndicats aussi le renouvellement
syndical ça peut durer ça
le renouvellement il y a eu il y a
quatre ans en arrière moment de la crise
des gilets jaunes que les syndicats
étaient morts ben oui mais regardez les
syndicats se sont mobilisés et ils sont
en échec oui mais ça c'est notre
question Guillaume on peut se demander à
quoi sert la grève mais ils ont été
capable et c'est sans doute les seuls de
mettre un million 270 000 personnes dans
la rue le 31 janvier et de faire tenir
un mouvement pendant 6 mois oui c'est
vrai ils ont été capables de montrer
en particulier à travers les grèves des
transports et des un certain nombre de
services publics une capacité de
nuisance qui est réelle mais ils n'ont
pas été capables de changer le cours de
cette réforme
ils n'ont rien fait bouger ça c'est
absolument donc ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie sociale c'est-à-dire le fait
que l'avenir du pays soit soit géré
conjointement avec les syndicats et bien
c'est un c'est un échec et donc en cela
je pense que les
des syndicats donc n'ont pas réussi moi
je me souviens de ces déclarations
donnéstruantes sur le pays qui allait
être mis à l'arrêt sur la CGT de
l'énergie qui d'expliquait que la France
allait se retrouver sans une goutte
d'essence et bah tout ça ça s'est pas
produit
alors une nouvelle page qui s'ouvre avec
deux femmes une à la tête de la CGT sauf
si binaire Marylise Léon a aussi c'est
toujours difficile de se relancer il y
en avait deux personnalités installées
avec Laurent Berger avec avec Philippe
Martinez là aussi est-ce qu'elles seront
capables d'agréger derrière elle je
pense que elles vont être différentes
parce que ce sont pas les mêmes
générations
ce sont pas non plus forcément la même
sensibilité moi j'ai j'ai entendu les
déclarations de ce féminin qui en fait
pas mal de bruit sur le fait que à
Roland-Garros ont demandé aux hôtesses
d'être maquillés et
d'avoir une jupe et que pour elle
c'était c'est vraiment des sujets sur
lesquels va la CGTS je ne vous le fais
pas dire et donc est-ce que ça veut dire
qui a une sorte de d'évolution sociétale
de de la CGT vers une forme de de
modernité wok j'en sais rien pour
l'instant ce sont des signaux faibles en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
peut-être que ce féminin
les conclusions de cet échec que nous
diagnostiquions à l'instant elle se dit
de toute façon le choc frontale ça ne
marche pas donc peut-être qu'il faut
plutôt être dans une dans une critique
plus plus
sociétal du système capitaliste
manifestation qui semble
on est proche de Montparnasse on a vu
sur ce plan oui il y a quelques instants
qu'il y avait assez peu de manifestants
devant la Tour Montparnasse 15h30 c'est
quoi la suite on va parler de quoi
désormais ce sont les prochains grands
sujets qui vont faire l'actualité
politique
je pense que le grand sujet c'est de
savoir si Emmanuel Macron arrive à
assortir de l'impasse
politique et institutionnel dans
laquelle il se trouve c'est à dire que
il est lui-même un des boulonnable
puisque il a été élu et bien élu mais il
n'a pas de majorité donc on a vu comment
il ne désespérait pas de trouver ça
c'est la première question déjà comment
régler finalement la crise technique
démocratique plus que les sujets je
pense qu'elles ne se règle pas cette
crise dans la mesure où la seule
solution c'est de revenir devant les
urnes mais alors effectivement ça peut
être un une sorte de de va tout du
président
qui pourrait prendre le risque d'A une
majorité rassemblement nationale avec un
Premier ministre issu de ce parti qui
échouerait et qui permettrait ensuite
aux parties du président de revenir tout
ça ce sont des plans sur la comète je
pense pas qu'Emmanuel Macron veuille
être l'homme qui a amené le
rassemblement national au pouvoir donc
je fais le même raisonnement pour le
l'opposition de gauche je pense pas que
que Emmanuel Macron et ce qu'il
soutiennent
souhaite lui voir prendre la moindre
initiative qui permettrait le risque de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à Matignon pour dire
des choses concrètement donc moi je ne
vois pas je vois un président qui est
condamné à faire beaucoup de discours ça
tombe bien c'est mieux ses activités
préférées et puis pour le reste
sur des sur des projets de loi trouver à
chaque fois des majorités de rencontres
et essayer de faire passer comme ça
quelques quelques mesures mais je pense
qu'on est dans une situation qui qui va
rester comme cela très très très très
très
imprécise alors ce n'est pas dramatique
en temps de paix entre guillemets et là
il se trouve que l'Europe est en guerre
mais là c'est le président qui a tous
les pouvoirs donc il y a pas de problème
et en plus nous ne sommes pas
directement concernés ce que je veux
dire par ce terme de temps de peste et
que c'est une grave crise survient je ne
sais pas
oui ou une là pour le coup
c'est c'est à nouveau le président qui
reprendrait la main qui pourrait avoir
une sorte de de l'Union nationale
derrière lui comme il y en a eu pendant
le covid et pour le reste ben voilà je
pense que
le pouvoir est
forcément
condamné à pouvoir
improviser je dirais presque bricoler
alors il y a eu un élément positif c'est
pas faire de plan sur la comète à 6 mois
non moi je mets en tout cas moi je n'en
ferai pas on va prendre les lois les
unes après les autres et puis c'est ça
et puis trouver des majorités alors il y
a une nouvelle positive pour le
gouvernement c'est que vous avez vu que
la la note de la dette française n'a pas
été dégradée donc il n'y a pas d'urgence
à faire un plan d'économie fort à
envoyer des signaux
radicaux au marché financier donc de ce
côté là Emmanuel Macron a gagné du temps
mais je vois pas ce qu'il peut faire de
cet en gagner le prochain grand sujet
est-ce que c'est la loi immigration
alors ça peut l'être ça peut l'être
puisque
Gérald var-manin a expliqué que il
tendait la main à la droite puisqu'on
voit bien que c'est de ce côté là que ça
va ça va se jouer pour cette histoire de
saucissonner la loi pour la faire voter
un peu par la gauche un peu par la
droite ça semble beaucoup c'est terminé
jusqu'à la prochaine fois je crois qu'il
y a eu cette changement de pieds sur ce
sur ce projet d'Emmanuel Macron qui
devrait avoir lieu dans l'heure on est
plus à ça près mais
les républicains ont fait quelque chose
d'assez intelligent tactiquement c'est
de mettre la barre très haut sur ce
projet pour réguler l'immigration avec
une mise entre parenthèses un certain
nombre de règles européennes en sachant
très bien que c'était un casus belli
pour pour Gérald Darmanin alors ce que
va faire le ministre de l'Intérieur à
mon avis c'est que en septembre il va
arriver avec un projet de loi avec
quelques mesures un peu ferme pas avant
septembre à mon avis non mais je je
crois que c'est plutôt ça le calendrier
il va arriver avec des mesures un peu
ferme en disant bah regardez nous vous
proposons de de de de rendre un peu plus
difficile l'immigration de de lutter
d'avoir plus efficacement contre le les
dérives du droit d'asile et la droite ne
veut pas voter avec nous ils sont
irresponsables et là il va essayer de
débaucher quelques quelques
parlementaires mais encore une fois on
est on est je pense condamné au réformes
et aux mesures merci beaucoup Guillaume
rocadeur on en parle dans 25 minutes
avec Guillaume Tabar qui ira pour la
question du jour et je vous la donne
déjà immigration faut-il revenir sur
l'accord dérogatoire franco-algérien de
1968 c'est pas simple c'est un peu
technique mais on vous explique tout
d'abord on retrouve Vincent roseron qui
est dans la manifestation nous on a une
image Vincent un peu en hauteur devant
la Tour Montparnasse
vous avez arrondissement il y a pas
grand monde et autour de vous c'est
comment
alors autour de moi il y a plus de monde
pour le coup ça avance la manifestation
avance là moi je me trouve actuellement
alors je me trouve plutôt dans la tête
de cortège dans la tête de cortège
officiel on va dire donc je pense que
les images qu'on a à Montparnasse ne
montre que des gens du cortège on va
dire non officiel des gens qui passent
devant parce que selon eux le cortège
n'avance pas assez vite et donc je pense
que c'est pour ça
je pense que c'est pour ça qu'il y a
qu'il y a qu'il y a moins de monde à
l'avant que vous voyez sur ces images
mais en tout cas ça pour être pour être
plus clair avec vous aussi quand même on
a eu l'impression lors de cette
manifestation d'avoir de voir des des
rancs par rapport à ce qu'on a eu
l'habitude de voir pour cette 14e
anniversaire même si même si on
discutant à droite à gauche il y a
toujours des gens très motivés qui
croient
mais aussi des gens résignés comme on
l'a vu avec Patrick canner le
dessinateur du Parti socialiste qu'on a
eu tout à l'heure et qui nous disait lui
que
qu'il fallait être là aujourd'hui même
si ce combat semble perdu et qu'il
fallait passer à autre chose en tout cas
donc voilà pour ce qu'on a vu pour nous
avec Julien Leclerc lors de cette
manifestation merci Thibault d'avoir été
en plateau merci à tous vos invités et
merci également aux internautes du
Figaro de nous avoir suivi on vous dit à
bientôt
voilà merci beaucoup Vincent roseron
vous a tout dit Vincent
avec ces images cette manifestation qui
doit évidemment arriver Place d'Italie
après cette élan c'est tout à l'heure
aux alentours de 14h depuis l'esplanade
des Invalides merci de nous avoir suivis
on se retrouve dans oui 20 minutes pour
la question du jour à tout à l'heure
[Musique]